in today's pushing the limits series
we're looking at the fate of thousands
of athletes who were training for the
olympic trials
when the pandemic hit the summer games
in tokyo were postponed until 2021
what has happened since has tested the
athletes limits in every way you can
think of nancy chen spoke
with several vying for a spot on team
usa including two
2016 olympians gymnast lori hernandez
and fencer
daryl homer as nancy shows us they had
to develop
a different kind of strength
[Music]
they're among the best athletes in the
world
used to training with top of the line
equipment
but along with so many others as the
pandemic hit
olympians like gymnast lori hernandez
had to find a way
to work from home my living room doesn't
really have
the best my coffee table can be the beam
those who felt like climbing the walls
did world champions lifted weights at a
local park
or in a garage next to holiday
decorations the artistic swimming team
synchronized by zoom
family pets became training partners
with the kids play room
or a new york city balcony transformed
into the gym
sometimes on the balcony the guy who
lived across from me oh you're fencing
right now
darrell homer won a silver medal in rio
in 2016. and is trying to make his third
olympic team
it was probably two and a half months
with very very limited training finding
a new place to run drills was far
from the only challenge for these elite
athletes whose lives and routines
are meticulously planned years in
advance
hernandez won gold and silver medals in
rio but like
other olympic hopefuls she now has to
wait
to qualify for the upcoming games
everybody was getting ready to peak and
then all of a sudden we're having to
come back down again
rescheduling the olympics means another
year of testing limits
financially mentally and physically
what do you like about trail running you
know it's quiet
runner kyle merber helped set a world
record in 2015.
the 29 year old had been hoping to
qualify for his first olympic team
and his final attempt to make it to the
games
i definitely felt deflated at first
everything that i do every single day
is kind of positioned in such a way that
i could run my best when it counts the
most
and then all of a sudden that is
stripped from you
the added year also means less money for
athletes
no longer winning financial prizes from
competitions
or sponsors that's been really tough for
a lot of different people out there just
trying to make ends meet and
i know a lot of their worries were like
okay can i even hang in there for next
year am i going to be able to
financially
hang on until the olympics dr lea lagos
is a clinical and sports psychologist
who treats olympic athletes
she calls burnout in the next year a
major concern
especially for athletes that have been
doing this for
a long time meaning you have athletes
going to the olympics that have trained
since they were four
and now they're 25. some athletes have
used the past few months to reflect
homer says the pause and training gave
him time to work on increasing diversity
in fencing
he also participated in black lives
matter protests this summer
i really believe in doing what you can
with what you have where you are
and that's kind of what i've been trying
to do
the olympic motto translates to faster
higher
stronger and the athletes hoping to be
crowned the best in the world
are now developing a new kind of
resilience and
purpose my latin with many redefining
what it means
to win no longer will i let the olympic
rings determine whether or not i've had
the success that i've hoped
it's just the day-to-day of enjoying
what you're doing and the pursuit
of it for cbs this morning nancy chen
new york very interesting piece
there you know there may be nothing
harder in this world than
uh having someone move the finish line
at the very end
when you've been working on it but i
like what daryl just said doing what you
can
with what you have with where you are
yeah but it's hard
these people literally have been
training their whole life exactly
exactly simple wisdom